foreign
[Music]
how to manage your cluster upgrades with
rollout sequencing with rollout
sequencing you can manage the order of
automatic cluster upgrades across your
environments before we continue you
should already be familiar with the
concepts of fleets and Scopes as well as
how clusters are upgraded with release
channels to recap in a previous video
we've seen how you can group Fleet
clusters into Scopes and we looked at
how Scopes are used for Team Management
in your Fleet in this video we look at
how fleets and Scopes can be used to
manage your cluster upgrades
now let's suppose you have your gke
clusters in multiple environments gke
releases a new kubernetes version for
your cluster's release Channel and you
want to upgrade your clusters but you
want to ensure that groups of clusters
are upgraded in a specific order
maybe you'd like to upgrade the Clusters
in the test environment first then the
staging environment and finally
production with rollout sequencing you
can sequence and upgrade between fleets
or if you further grouped your clusters
into Scopes then you can sequence and
upgrade between scopes
let's look at how this works with some
examples
streamtech is a company running their
gke clusters on version 1.25
they've organized their clusters into
two fleets staging and production
all their clusters are enrolled in the
regular release channel for automatic
upgrades when a new version is released
streamtech would like to follow this
sequence for testing the new version
first they want the staging clusters to
be upgraded
then they want to wait a week to confirm
that the upgrade was successful in the
staging Fleet
once they've confirmed those workloads
are running as expected they want the
upgrade to roll out to the production
clusters
this process of defining the order in
which you want fleets upgraded is called
creating a rollout sequence
the waiting period of 7 days is referred
to as soaking time in other words the
amount of time that should elapse
between each rollout so streamtech goes
ahead and creates a rollout sequence
with these specifications
now let's assume a new version 1.26 is
scheduled for the 1st of May
since streamtech has enrolled all their
clusters in a release channel the
upgrade begins automatically on or after
May 1st in this sequence
gke upgrades all clusters in the staging
Fleet to 1.26
once the upgrade and the staging Fleet
is complete the soaking period in this
case 7 Days begins
when the soaking period is complete gke
begins upgrading the Clusters in the
production Fleet
now let's look at another company
they've organized their gke clusters
into fleets and scopes
they have their clusters on two
different versions in the two Scopes and
they want different upgrade targets for
these clusters so they've enrolled the
Clusters in two different release
channels
the web server teams clusters in the
regular release Channel and the database
management teams clusters in the stable
release Channel
Nexus retail wants upgrades to roll out
in a certain order between their Scopes
so they create these rollout sequences
for the web server team scope the
rollout sequence indicates that the
scope in the testing Fleet should
upgrade first followed by the scope in
the staging Fleet and finally the scope
in the production Fleet
the platform admin also doesn't want any
soaking time so the rollout to the next
scope can begin as soon as the previous
one is complete
for the database management team score
the rollout sequence defines the same
order but here the platform admin also
wants a soaking time of 5 days between
each rollout now let's assume version
1.26 is available in the stable channel
gke will upgrade the database management
teams clusters in the testing Fleet
first
then the soaking time of 5 days begins
when this is complete gke upgrades the
Clusters in the staging Fleet and after
another soaking period of 5 days
upgrades the Clusters in the production
Fleet let's also assume version 1.27 is
now available in the regular release
Channel
since the Clusters in the web server
scope are enrolled in this channel gke
will first upgrade those clusters in the
testing Fleet
once the Clusters are upgraded and since
there is no soaking time specified gke
will begin upgrading the Clusters in the
staging Fleet and then move on to the
production Fleet
as you can see from these examples if
you want to manage cluster upgrades with
rollout sequencing then you have to
organize your clusters into fleets and
Scopes if you want to manage a
scope-based rollout
all clusters in a rollout sequence
should be in the same release Channel
and minor version to successfully
upgrade to new versions
in this video you've seen how rollout
sequencing gives you even more control
over the upgrade process than just using
release channels for more information
check out our documentation thanks for
watching
[Music]
foreign